[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
the biden administration has made it
clear its foreign policy will be
informed by the protection
and spread of western liberal values it
would seem
values are far more important than
national and economic security
not surprisingly not all countries in
the world are in agreement with biden's
vision
for the global order
[Music]
crosstalking the liberal world order i'm
joined by my guest brian becker in
washington
he's the executive director of the anser
coalition in
london we have met horsharp he is a
professor of political science
and international relations at coventry
university
and in budapest we have george samueli
he is a podcaster at the gaggle which
can be found on youtube
and rumble all right gentlemen crosstalk
girls in effect that means you can jump
in anytime you want and i always
appreciate it let me go to george first
in budapest um we had that confab with
the chinese in anchorage which turned
into a train wreck
uh because the secretary of state was
more concerned about
uh china's internal affairs and not
measuring up to western liberal values
uh however you want to define them and
then we had the secretary of state
in meeting with uh with nato allies a
few days
ago and he talked about values 17 times
but george
i didn't see international law mentioned
once
so what's going on here i mean what is
the playing field international law
or liberal values as how the west
interprets it
go ahead well that's exactly right
um what we have is the western powers
that have defined a rules-based order
as something that they appreciate they
set the rules
and they issue the orders and everyone
has to comply towards them
there is now an alternative model um
which is uh advocated by russia and
china
which is let us return to the
westphalian
system of states which is that all
states
are sovereign within their own territory
no state can interfere in the internal
affairs of another state no state
can threaten and use any kind of
coercion not just military coalition
economic coercion
against any other state and then these
principles these westphalian principles
were enshrined in the united nations
charter and so when when the united
states starts talking about
values and that they intend to spread
values
intent to spread democracy then there
are very few takers
because uh most of the world will find
the
russian and chinese model much more
appealing which is
we don't really want uh what you're
selling
that is what they're going to say to the
united states and its sundry allies in
nato
okay mata in london as i said in my my
introduction here
i mean this this this what we're getting
from this administration is a
reliance on so-called values but what
about economic security
military security all of these things
here which the nation state
you know it needs to do to protect its
interests i mean
it doesn't seem to be much of an
interest-driven foreign policy
when you're trying to change the
internal affairs of another country go
ahead matt in london
well the international order is also an
economic order
uh for there to be a a liberal free
trade system which is one of america's
interests which is a value
there traditionally has to be a hegemon
there has to be a country
that carries the burdens america is by a
considerable distance
the only superpower economically as well
as military in the world
and america therefore taking it upon
itself to establish
uh an order that everybody else can
benefit from
it's a bit like lighthouses and economic
theory some people who are very rich
will build lighthouses
and the other people will then be able
to navigate on the sea
uh because of that uh great power
and when it's been said that uh one
cannot interfere with the
the internal affairs in a country well
it is actually if you look at the
uh un charter that was mentioned before
which was
drawn up including the countries that is
the present day russia
said there should be democracy freedom
of speech
which is not exactly what you see if you
live in china
and and also sadly not the case in
russia
so russia which used to be a country
with a great tradition
for for for the rule of law uh if you
look at the first constitution written
by catherine the great
it had all those things russia is a
couture nation
russia is a place that people like me
love
the likes of dostoyevsky the bolshoi
ballet tchaikovsky
and all the writers and i would hope
that russia
which used to be in the camp of of
liberal democracy
would return to where russia belongs to
be a progressive
western okay well let me let me let me
go to brian here so
if we if we extrapolate from what we
just heard from matt so
the us should use military force to
bring democracy around the world
i think we've seen quite a few examples
of that recently
i wonder i wonder i'm sorry let me go
let me get my third guest in and you can
react i promise i'll go right back to
you
so brian you know i mean it's like
madeleine albright when we stand taller
we see further
i mean that was during the crisis uh
breaking up of yugoslavia
the illegal invasion of iraq and tooth i
could go on and on and on so i
i had jamon maybe can have good
intentions but that's not power
politics go ahead brian in washington
well and and i would actually dispute
the the good intentions part i mean i
think the whole referencing of values
is largely uh a pretext it's largely a
public for public consumption
uh to disguise what is basically a naked
self-interested a foreign policy that
aims to dominate
or dislodge or topple governments that
are independent
uh independent meaning that they have
the capacity to control their own
uh labor their own land their own
resources
and to be politically independent rather
than submissive
and so the united states in in this day
and age says
we're doing this for a noble cause we're
doing this to bring democracy or in the
case of libya it was to protect
civilians or in iraq it was to stop
weapons of mass destruction
or in afghanistan it was to stop
terrorism i mean there's always
something good
something america presents itself as an
exceptional country that's disinterested
in in real things and only is promoting
values
but in fact i believe that the values
are
are really just a shield i mean the the
talk about
values and and really what the united
states is trying to do by
emphasizing the issue of values for
instance
is it's trying to create or commit or
carry out other
what we might call color revolutions
against targeted countries so
the us looks at where the
vulnerabilities might be in the case of
china so
it's like suddenly america cares about
muslims as long as they're in china
suddenly america cares about taiwan
again suddenly america carries a
cares so much about hong kong and
democracy there it doesn't care about
these things in saudi arabia the values
if the
if the values are consistent values they
could be consistently applied
but they're only selectively applied
against targeted governments and so
i believe it's a very aggressive very
hegemonic
uh foreign policy military policy and
and let's face it
the the there's been a reorientation of
u.s military doctrines so that the war
on terror is
all yesterday now it's major power
conflict so in order to take the
the american people to war against china
or conflict with china or russia
you have to convince them that they're
very evil and what makes them evil
they don't have our values okay matt in
latin in london i'll let you to reply
okay go ahead
yes no i think i emphatically did not
say that you should use
force to invade other countries i think
that the invasion in iraq was a mistake
uh whether it was technically legal
because there were a number of
u.n security council resolutions that
could be argued that it possibly was
legal i personally as
however it was certainly illegal it was
certainly illegal for russia to invade
uh ukraine uh and that's not respecting
the borders
okay well that's assuming that russia
did invade
ukraine what invasion of ukraine
when did that happen
one thing we know for sure that the
democratically elected government and
kiev
was toppled illegally we have a
victorian newlands voice we have the
american ambassador
to ukraine talking about how it was all
done so
i don't know if there was an invasion of
ukraine but there certainly was an
illegal overthrow of a democratically
elected
government george you're you're in
you're in dismay george go ahead
well exactly i mean when we start
talking about um
illegal uh invasions uh
and then we look at the record of the
west uh
and compare that with uh russia i mean
it's a joke
i mean when we're talking about um iraq
i mean
you know it's it's it's laughable even
to start talking about
uh the invasion of iraq being possibly
illegal i mean
you know the former u.n secretary
general kofi annan himself said
no it is not legal there was no way that
you can justify it
um according to international law the
only way he can become legal
would have been a resolution from the
united nations security council
and no less than three three permanent
members
of the united nations security council
uh who vetoed any kind of a resolution
uh to use force against uh iraq so
there's you know no question that it's
illegal
and the same goes for the uh onslaught
on the
yugoslavia happened uh just over 20
years ago
again the only way you could have
justified it as legal
is if you've gone to the united nations
security council that's it
it's in the u.n charter if you're going
to use force two conditions
either it's self-defense or if it's
authorized by the security council
it wasn't authorized by the security
council in fact the security council was
strongly opposed to it and so when we
start talking about
who's violating international law i
think this sort of the spokesman for the
west
really should um you know hold their
piece on this one
okay brian i'm going to give you the uh
last minute before we go to the break go
ahead jump in
yes uh what what we're witnessing right
now is a very expansive
u.s war drive and a full-court press
against russia and china
uh what what what trump did and also
biden is
there's a lot of continuity here same
thing that reagan did in the 80s
maximum pressure on these countries
reagan had something called
captive nations trying to liberate the
oppressed republics in the soviet union
all of it designed for maximum pressure
for regime change
or what became color revolutions we have
to understand that it's really
the values element of it is really
pretextual it's a public rationale
behind it is kind of naked old style
colonialism
dressed up with a new outfit all right
gentlemen i'm going to jump in here
we're going to go to a short break and
after that short break we'll continue
our discussion on the liberal world
order stay with rt
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lebel to
remind you we're discussing the liberal
world order
[Music]
okay let's go back to matt in london i
think one of the things i find really
very peculiar is that mr blinken the
secretary of state
has been really quite active and and
very much in public
um trying to explain the
administration's
uh policy uh on the world stage and his
constant obsession with this democracy
issue which i think everyone
i think nominally speaking democracy is
a good idea but you know
it's really kind of rich coming from the
secretary of state when
after the november election tens of
millions of people have doubts about the
democratic process in the united states
itself so i mean isn't it kind of
peculiar to you that the secretary of
state
goes on the world stage well it's deeply
divided at home
go ahead in london america is deeply
divided it's a polarized society but in
america people have the right
to express their opinion there is no
indication
i repeat no indication that the election
was fraudulent in any way
it is the fairest election that has ever
been in american history
america is not a perfect democracy
america is an imperfect democracy
but it would be better that america
strives to become
a perfecter democracy um
and uh and it's um it's it's perfectly
laudable uh to uh defend democracy
uh america has a proud tradition of
democracy it is the oldest democracy in
the world
uh it's always been an imperfect
democracy but america
uh in america you have the right to you
know but don't you think matt you know
overthrowing the legal government in
iran
in ukraine we could make program after
program about
how the united states attacked democracy
all around the world because it doesn't
have the democracy it wants for
geopolitical reasons
you know it's it's not democracy is the
problem it's who's
who's in power and even if it's the
democratic process
they still do that i mean the the number
of
elected governments and latin america
that have been overthrown
um by the outside forces here i mean you
know allowable
democracy i mean i i really have no idea
what you're getting at here
george you know jump in here i mean this
is this is like
and i think nobody i think you probably
do no in america
it's a it's a cudgel it's a cudgel for
power
okay it's not about a principle go ahead
george
well that's exactly right uh and this is
an
ongoing thing so um many of the
apologists for
u.s foreign policy will say yeah it's
true that we did this with masadek in
iran
in 53 yeah it's true we did this with
our benson guatemala 54.
yeah it's true we overthrew allende that
was 73 but that was all a long time ago
no it wasn't a long time ago the
overthrow of the
uh government of ukraine and we know the
united states is involved we have a
record of
the telephone conversation between
victoria newland and the uh us
ambassador and
jeffrey pion we know what they were up
there that's just a few years ago
this is an ongoing thing that the united
states
is always doing and that's where it's
sort of it's it's uh
laudable elections well we get into the
situation
in which uh the losing side
does not accept the outcome of an
election let's
let's go back to 2016. we know in 2016
the losing side the democrats
refused to accept that outcome and serve
to
undermine that election so now we've got
the 2020 election
and again the losing side does not
accept the outcome
and we can be absolutely certain that
given the 50 50 country the united
states is at the moment that the 2024
election will be very close and we can
be sure
that the losing side will not accept
that outcome so in other words
the very basis of democracy which is the
losing side says okay we lost
uh you are now the government that's
gone that's not there in the united
states so it is a little hard
for the united states to go around
lecturing the world about the
perfections of democracy
you know brian you know hang on let me
go back to brian
everyone gets equal time here i'm going
to go to brian in washington you know
brian go
go let's go back to the anchorage uh
confab
um blinken wanted to talk about the the
uyghurs he wanted to talk about hong
kong
he wanted to talk about taiwan well
would it be fair on the chinese part to
say well what's going on in flint
michigan why don't your people have
clean water maybe we should take this to
the security council i mean their human
rights are being denied the civil rights
are being denied
under american law i mean it it's it you
know you could you can
both sides have their own fair share to
lecture each other but maybe it would
have been better to talk about
um um navigation ip
tariffs i mean these are things that
actually impact
national interest and your own citizens
that's what diplomacy used to be it
wasn't like it is today like it's a
sermon today go ahead brian
yeah you're quite right peter that was
that's a really important point i mean
the united states invited the chinese to
come to the united states alaska is part
of the united states
so the the host brings the guests there
and immediately at the beginning
dresses down the guest and says look
you're violating all of these
uh human rights issues in china
in your own country taiwan hong kong
shenzhen all part of china and then says
it's a violation of the international
rules-based order
and as a consequence we're going to
focus on it and then the chinese
diplomats had the temerity to say well
wait
you're an imperfect democracy what about
black lives matter
what about the suppression of black
people for not just since george floyd
but for a long time
etc etc and then the american press
denounces the chinese diplomats for
being
insubordinate and speaking up and saying
obvious truths which they had no
intention of saying but they're not
going to be lectured to
so here you have the united states up on
the pedestal
acting like it's bringing the the 10th
or maybe the 11th commandment the 11th
commandment is
listen to us we are god and the rest of
the world's like
no thank you we don't want to do that
we're not going to bow and be submissive
to you
and so as the chinese said you have no
no
ability to to lecture us from a position
of strength
because in fact the american empire is
in decline
it's not completely gone obviously it
has a lot of power
but the fact of the matter is the united
states has gone to war
constantly endlessly it's a warfare
state and even though yes your other
guests are right that america's
polarized when it comes to spending a
trillion dollars a year
each year every year that's five times
more than
china and ten times more than russia
annually on that there is unanimity
between the republicans and the
democrats yeah so it's only on the issue
of america
projection of power and military power
that america can find some semblance of
unity
that's a that's like the roman empire in
decline the only thing we can unite
around
is our enemies our perceived enemies or
the enemies we want to make in the world
let's go back to matt in london matt we
we the
high commissioner for uh foreign affairs
uh joseph burrell was in
moscow uh in the last few weeks and he
pulled the kind of the full
the same stunt that uh blinken did and
he was rebuked very strongly
and then we had obviously um lincoln in
anchorage
um people are pushing back major powers
are pushing back
i mean this things are changing how do
you think this is going to play out
if uh major powers in the world start
saying no
well i think which to start with would
be interesting to see if people were
actually be allowed i don't know if
people are allowed to listen to this
even in russia
now people are not allowed to protest in
russia that's not
true at all you don't there are protests
all of the time here all you have to do
is get a permit
and you can do it you can you can
protest
all you want on the internet i'm sorry
matt you should have
an informed opinion before you express
an opinion i have informed opinion
people are being jailed for trivialities
that wouldn't happen in america people
are pushing back people have been pushed
back in places like belarus people are
pushing back in russia
people have been pushed back pushing
back in the lights of peter
peter right now i'm sorry
right now in minnesota indigenous people
are being brutalized and beaten while
they're praying because they don't want
to
pipeline through their territory that's
going on right now in minnesota not
alabama it's all over the country
and the idea that people aren't being
arrested and brutalized for trivial acts
your speaker actually from london
doesn't actually know what's going on in
the united states
well what about i do know what's going
on in the united states no you don't
you obviously don't george can i say
something go ahead
for people being arrested i mean we've
seen now that we have the
uh the protesters number of the
protesters who took part in
on january the sixth have been uh in
jail
for months now months uh without bail
and which is an unheard of thing i mean
another you know people who have not
been
uh charged with any crimes of violence
are actually being imprisoned and who
have not been convicted of anything
uh that's right i mean uh you know with
protesters
so really you know what should would one
shouldn't start pointing fingers
at others when you're falling short so
badly at home
okay look at the united kingdom
let's go to matt i said everyone would
get equal time go ahead matt
i hope this time i won't be interrupted
because i'm stating an opinion which is
broadly shared now america is not a
perfect democracy
but one sin does not justify another the
fact that sins are being committed in
china it does not make sense in america
right
you should be criticizing all tyrants
all over
but there are some tyrants that are
greater than other tyrants
and i think liberty and freedom can only
exist if we criticize
i think we shouldn't fall into this trap
of of fake
news and say that ukraine's government
was over
and if this channel is going to have any
credibility start
to look at actual facts not just the
facts that seem to be convenient
to to the various people it's the oldest
trick in the book
to come up with alternative histories
that's what augustine did
that's been the history of tyranny all
over the world
that doesn't want to be interrupted but
he just talks to josh hang on hang on
hang on we're almost out of time brian
go ahead
i mean the okay come on february 22nd
there was an
armed insurgent uprising in kiev
that toppled the government the
president yanukovych fled for his life
he would have been killed otherwise
i mean the idea that this did not happen
that the
the idea that it was a fake news i mean
we can't we
whatever side you are you have to take
actual reality for what it is
the government in the ukraine was
toppled by a coordinated effort by the
united states by the cia by the national
endowment for democracy this actually
happened matt
it's not made up it's real it happened
and the moonlighting was fake yeah
oh all righty guys that was a very
interesting alternative history lesson
that's all the time we have
many thanks to my guests in washington
london and in budapest and thanks to our
viewers for watching us here at rt see
you next time and remember crosstalk
[Music]
rules